♪♪
>> IT'S DECISION TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA TO DETERMINE IF
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM WILL KEEP
HIS JOB.
THE POLLS CLOSE IN A FEW HOURS
AND DEMOCRATS ARE PULLING OUT
ALL THE STOPS.
UNBELIEVABLE WHAT HAPPENED THE
FINAL FEW WEEKS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN TRYING TO MAKE
THE RECALL ALL ABOUT TRUMP
INSTEAD OF NEWSOME'S JOB
PERFORMANCE.
>> ALL OF YOU KNOW IN THE LAST
YEAR I GOT RUN AGAINST THE REAL
DONALD TRUMP.
THIS YEAR, THIS YEAR, LEADING
REPUBLICAN RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR
IS THE CLOSEST THING TO A TRUMP
CLONE THAT I'VE EVER SEEN IN
YOUR STATE.
YOU EITHER KEEP GAVIN NEWSOM AS
YOUR GOVERNOR, OR YOU'LL GET
DONALD TRUMP.
>> ALL RIGHT, THAT WAS
INSPIRING.
NEWSOME CONTINUED TO PUSH RACE
BASED ATTACKS AGAINST LEADING
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE LARRY
ELDER.
>> THE ISSUE OF DIVERSITY,
PLURALISM.
THE ISSUE THAT DEFINES SO MUCH
OF OUR POLITICS, THAT'S ALL ON
THE BALLOT TOMORROW NIGHT.
RACIAL JUSTICE IS ON THE BALLOT
TOMORROW NIGHT.
>> Brian:.
>> Brian: MAN HE'S LOOKED
NERVOUS UNSURE OF HIMSELF
THROUGHOUT THE RECALL.
HE'S CALLED OUT THE PRESIDENT,
THE VICE-PRESIDENT, THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE, SENATOR ELIZABETH
WARREN AND RAISED $70 MILLION.
DOES THAT SHOW THEY'RE NERVOUS
OR IS THAT DEMOCRATS SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO WIN BIG AND WE
ALL WANT CREDIT FOR IT.
>> Dana: FIVE, SIX WEEKS AGO I
THINK THEY WERE VERY NERVOUS
ESPECIALLY AS LARRY ELDER
STARTED PICKING UP SPEED.
HE ALREADY HAS STATE WIDE NAME
ID, WHICH IS HARD TO GET.
BUT BECAUSE LARRY ELDER HAD IT
AND HE'S VERY POPULAR AND HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES.
HE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP OR BIDEN OR KAMALA HARRIS.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS, CRIME, EDUCATION,
AND THE ECONOMY.
AND HE WAS WORRIED THAT PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA WERE WANTING TO
LEAVE.
AND ANYTIME THAT I SAW GAVIN
NEWSOM GET OUT THERE AND TRY TO
CAMPAIGN, ONE, HE DIDN'T SEEM
AUTHENTIC, HE WAS KIND OF VERY
ANGRY DIDN'T SEEM LIKE HIM, HE
WASN'T TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES
AND THEY SO BADLY WANT TO RUN
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP THAT ACE
LITTLE BIT BIT OF A TELL FOR THE
2020 MIDTERMS.
THE OTHER THING IF YOU'RE THE
COMMANDER OF CHIEF AND LEFT THE
ENEMY STRANDED BEHIND ENEMY
LINES IN AFGHANISTAN.
I WOULD SPEND ALL MY TIME ON
THAT.
I WOULDN'T GO TO CALIFORNIA.
I WOULDN'T CAMPAIGN.
I WOULD MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
KNOWS I'M GOING TO GET THESE
PEOPLE OUT
>> Brian: WHY DID HE SHOW UP.
>> JESSE: HE'S CAMPAIGNING IN
THE MIDDLE OF AN PANDEMIC.
WE CAN PLAY THAT GAME, TOO.
TRUMP IS NOW THE WEDGE ISSUE FOR
DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS WHAT THEY'VE DONE.
SO YOU'RE EITHER A TRUMP
REPUBLICAN AND THAT FIRES UP THE
DEMOCRAT BASE, OR IF YOU TRY TO
DISTANCE YOURSELF FROM TRUMP,
THE REPUBLICAN BASE GOES CRAZY
AND HATES YOU.
SO THAT COULD WORK IN A STATE
LIKE CALIFORNIA WHERE
REPUBLICANS ARE OUTNUMBERED, BUT
THAT'S NOT REALLY GOING TO PLAY
IN SWING DISTRICTS NEXT FALL.
IT'S A LAZY ARGUMENT.
BUT THE REAL ISSUE IMMIGRATION
HAS KILLED THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE FOREIGN BORN POPULATION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS 25%.
FOREIGN BORN VOTERS VOTE 2-1
DEMOCRAT.
YOU DO AMNESTY, YOU DO THOSE
SPECIAL VISAS, GREEN CARDS,
CHAIN MIGRATION, BIRTH RIGHT
AMNESTY, YOU'RE LOADING IT UP.
WE ALREADY KNOW THEY VOTE 2-1
DEMOCRAT, ASIANS 2-1 DEMOCRAT,
BLACKS 2-1 DEMOCRAT.
IN A STATE LIKE THAT IF YOU
THROW OUT A LOT OF NASTY RACIAL
ATTACKS TO THAT POPULATION, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE NOT ALL PAYING
ATTENTION THAT MUCH TO POLITICS,
THAT'S GOING TO MOVE THE NEEDLE.
AND THEN YOU THROW IN THE
$70 MILLION IN ADVERTISING
APPEAR THE GUY'S GOOD LOOKING,
GREAT HEAD OF HAIR, CHARISMA,
WELL TANNED.
A LOT OF PEOPLE PAY ATTENTION TO
THAT KIND OF STUFF.
I DON'T PERSONALLY, AT ALL.
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE DO.
>> Brian: VERY SIMILAR HAIR
STYLE HEAD SET.
FOR MORE ON THAT LET'S GO TO
JESSICA.
JESSICA WHY DID THEY NOT BRING
UP THINGS HE DID WELL?
WHY DON'T THEY SAY HE'S DONE A
GREAT JOB BRINGING UP THE
HOMELESS POPULATION, RAISING
TAXES?
WHY DON'T THEY BRING UP SOME
THINGS HE DID WELL?
HOW COME THEY'RE ALWAYS JUST
SAYING YOU DON'T WANT DONALD
TRUMP.
>> Jessica: YOU DON'T WANT
DONALD TRUMP OR YOU DO WANT
DONALD TRUMP IS THE MOST
ANIMATING ISSUE IN AMERICA AND
CONTINUES TO BE THAT WAY.
AND IT'S JUST NOT GOING TO
CHANGE EVEN THROUGH THE
MIDTERMS.
AND JESSE IS RIGHT, NOT ABOUT
THE HAIR THING.
I MEAN, HE IS, GAVIN NEWSOME IS
VERY GOOD LOOKING BUT THAT DOES
NOT GET YOU A GOVERNORSHIP.
BUT COMING OUT RIGHT NOW AND
SAYING THAT LARRY --
>> WHAT HAS HE DONE WELL?
WHAT HAS NEWSOM DONE WELL?
WHAT HAS HE DONE WELL.
>> GREAT QUESTION.
>> Jessica: THE PRESSURE LAUNDRY
IS LOVELY.
I DIDN'T GO DURING THE PANDEMIC.
>> BESIDES THAT WHAT DID HE DO
WELL.
>> PEOPLE IN THE STATE HE HAD A
VERY HIGH APPROVAL RATING.
>> WHAT HAS HE DONE WELL
JESSICA?
>> Jessica: WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO SAY ABOUT
IT.
CAN I JUST SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
WHO'S VOTING IN CONTRAST TO WHAT
JESSE WAS SAYING, YES, YOU HAVE
A LATINO POPULATION THAT TENDS
TO VOTE DEMOCRAT THAT IS
SHIFTING.
YOU ALSO HAVE A CONSERVATIVE
POPULATION ASIAN REPRESENTATIVES
THAT SPENT MORE ASIAN
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE IN 2020.
THOSE MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
THEY WON'T SHIFT THE RECALL.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS ARE AWARE OF A
SHIFTING TIED IN TERMS OF HOW A
MINORITY POPULATION IS VOTING
AND HE'S BRINGING UP RACIAL
ISSUES NOT TO SAY LARRY ELDER IS
A WHITE SUPREMACIST BUT TO SAY
ONE PARTY, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS THE ONE PAYING ATTENTION TO
THE RACIAL INE QUALITY ISSUES.
>> HE HAS THE MEADE WHY ON HIS
SIDE.
FOR THEM TO NOT HAVE THE WHITE
WOMAN IN A GRASRY A MASK
THROWING EGGS AT HIM.
>> THEY CALLED IT AN EGG
THROWING INCIDENT.
AND THEN THE LA TIMES VICIOUSLY
USED A PHOTO OF LARRY ELDER IN A
MOMENT WHERE HE WAS MOVING
TOWARDS SOMEONE HE KNOWS, LOOKED
LIKE HE WAS HITTING HER, ON THE
STORY, LIKE THIS, AND SAID HE
HAD TO LEAVE THIS HOMELESS
ENKAVRMENT BECAUSE THERE WAS AN
INCIDENT LARRY ELDER IMPLYING HE
WAS ENGAGED WITH THIS WOMAN
INSTEAD HE WAS BEING ATTACKED BY
A WHITE WOMAN IN A GORILLA FACE.
I WILL SAY IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
SINCE RONALD REAGAN WAS THE
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA BUT
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN MAKING
UP GROUND IN THE MORE
CONSERVATIVE DISTRICTS AND I
THINK THAT PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA,
INCLUDING MINORITIES, CARE A LOT
ABOUT CRIME AND HOMELESSNESS
AFFECTING THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
THE PLACES THEY LIVE.
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME, TO ASK
THE QUESTION TO SOMEONE LIKE
GAVIN NEWSOM OR PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN, ARE ALL THE DEMOCRATS ARE
VOTING AGAINST GAVIN NEWSOM
DONALD TRUMP?
ARE ALL THE DEMOCRATS RUNNING
AGAINST GAVIN NEWSOM THE SAME
THING AS DONALD TRUMP?
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
REPUBLICANS AND LARRY ELDER WHO
WANT TO RECALL THE GOVERNOR.
THERE ARE A LOT OF INDEPENDENT